first of all Jake thanks for doing this
with us no of course thank you thank you
for having me this is it's I've never
done an interview on like a call like
this this is your first soom interview
oh yeah 100% I feel so honored how how
is life right now how it's quarantine
going for you kind of walk me through
life is good yeah really good actually I
mean I think people I'm starting to lose
my mind definitely a little bit in
quarantine as you could tell we clearly
have nothing to do we're getting pretty
bored but I'm just like developing like
new routines and like new habits and I'm
actually getting to do stuff that I
normally don't get to do and being able
to spend I'm like some of my friends but
I like just got and like new random
hobbies that are just like weird and I
cleaning out like my truck and
organizing it lots of working out I try
to work out every day in quarantine I
feel like that's the thing that like
keeps me the most
who are you quarantined with and where
are you in LA right now yes on that my
house actually in LA and there's a bunch
of us here there's probably 12 people in
here but oh is that does that mean we're
like breaking a rule cuz technically
can't you have not I think I think
that's a few too many people but are you
guys like leaving and coming back or
y'all just like staying there worse for
the most part we're staying here some
people go to the grocery store but I was
I was just driving right now
and there's traffic like tons of cars
are out so I'm confused as to like what
people are doing yeah I feel like we
need more people to take this seriously
which is what I was gonna ask you is I
know that you're still uploading videos
so is this content that you're shooting
right now like in life like current time
or is it old footage like how is that
sort of working for you right now
yeah it's current um we're just very
careful about like what we're filming
and we're just having to like come up
with stuff to do at the house
I actually filmed in one of my videos my
my videographer actually like left to go
hang out with the girl yeah and so we
caught him and like put him on blast in
front of everyone and we doused him in
hand sanitizer and I just made sure that
everyone was never gonna leave the house
again so yeah did you see you let him
back in but not until after you'd asked
him and hand sanitizer yeah but yeah and
I think I just like made him take it
more seriously I do have to ask you
about Julia Rose because you guys broke
up but then you got back together so I
want you to walk me through what
happened
I saw the billboard in your video which
was wild how much did that cost by the
way I think it was like - yeah kind of
walk me through what what happened like
what caused the break-up so we so we we
were just like arguing a lot over stupid
stuff and we just like realized like and
I was getting mad at her and then I was
being mean and she was being mean and
then it was just it just was a lot and
so she was just like oh I need to like
step back from this then I was like
chasing after her and like a little bit
and she liked that and we kind of
realized that we got away from like our
roots which was like why we like first
like fell in love and and we kind of
just went back to our roots and fix the
communication and fix some issues and
then or we're great now so it's super
exciting so everything is good I know in
the past don't get mad at me
but people have wondered if your
relationships are authentic if you will
is this the real deal like you said you
drop the Elle we're just now yeah it's
real it's real for sure
yeah I'm hi oh my all the relationships
yeah there's a there's a line where some
of it's real and some of it's not but
this one's definitely real for sure and
what's cool about my relationship with
Julia is
for the most part for like the first
like I think almost like six months it
was all off-camera and we it wasn't
public or anything so that was really
cool and it's awesome to be able to
build like a relationship off-camera
without like Hollywood and all the
critics and fans and drama and all that
stuff so yeah are really our
relationship does a really solid
foundation why have you decided to start
putting some of it on on camera I think
it's I think it's almost inevitable
because like I've always filled my whole
entire life and so I was like it's hard
like what people watch is my lifestyle
essentially so it's hard it would be
harder to not film it and make it like
we're like if we're all me something
natural that's happening and she's just
like wants to be involved with I can't
it would just make it weird so both of
you guys do post some I want to say like
NSFW stuff like either if it's in the
videos or if it's a picture like where
do you draw the line of what I mean you
guys Joe Cubao making a porn all the
time
so we know so so we did do that so but
it's like it was just like you know I
mean it was hot but it's more so whether
or not we're dropping it which I which I
don't would think we are but my brother
my brother said he was gonna start like
a GoFundMe for fans to like raise a
certain amount of money for us to drop
it would would you ever drop something
like that like is there a line there
would she be okay with that I don't I
don't think so
I think that's that a hands where the
line definitely gets drawn but I don't
know I have it like maybe if the price
is right well how much would it take for
you to release that like probably like
five now five of them know I have 210
Mellon you and you guys would just split
you would do it yeah because our
generation like well I guess like the
kids growing up now and like sort of me
like we never had like any big celebrity
like sex tape leaking so you would want
to be that you would fill that void I
don't know I'd be the one to fill the
void but like I feel like we need to
stir the pot a little bit like well like
what's the last celebrity sex tape that
like well I don't know I guess that Kim
Java there was Kim's but that was a long
time ago that's all I'm saying we needed
a new one this should be a thing this
should be a thing I also I forgot to ask
you so Julia said that she wanted you to
get a tattoo of her name on your body
did you end up doing that I didn't I
didn't get the tattoo of her name are
you planning to do that or no I might I
might do that okay
all right all right we get a second
wedding out of you that's really what I
want to know I think if it so I've
talked about it with Julia and we like
death we wouldn't get married like on
camera I think we would get married for
real and and then like and throw like a
secret wedding and then do one for
camera like soon or is this like way in
the future
I think like in the future how long in
the future you better not go and get
married in two weeks I'm not I don't
think I'm doing that I don't know like I
might do it before the end of the year I
ain't scared I ain't scared I'm trying
to be a young dad you know what I'm
saying
are you really I want to be like a cool
young dad you guys talked about this
yeah we were talking about it today with
our other friend his parents he's like
21 and his parents are like 38 and 39
that's crazy that's awesome though
because you can like keep up with your
kids that way
yeah they can be best friends a point
yeah yeah okay so the plan is to be a
young dad I love that for you look at
that
[Music]
okay
I did see okay so you posted a video
where her and Tana got into a fake fight
but then they started making out those
Wyatt
how does Tana kind of feel used to would
have moved on pretty quickly so were you
in Tana the real was that also real yeah
it wasn't it was how do I say this
you're gonna tell anyone it should be me
I feel like I've been so involved at
this point yeah that's true
I think it was about as real make an
analogy no it was not listen we all do
things sometimes and some people
sometimes you end up getting fake
married so I'll leave it at that okay so
she's not bothered then that you are for
real dating Julia Rose
I don't think so now what about tannaz
new song a lot of people think it's
about you it's called without you um I
don't know if it's about me she she also
has like a new boyfriend I think as well
who has heard a boyfriend I didn't know
that I
I think it's Maude son that fella thorns
ex right
yeah but she's friends with Bella Thorne
listen crazy in Hollywood things get
crazy in Hollywood how is your brother
doing is your brother quarantined with
you he's doing good as well uh we've
actually hung out once during quarantine
we were debating whether or not we
should because of the social distancing
and we kind of broke that rule but he's
doing good we're just making content
really there's there's nothing to do man
it's like I don't know like it hits a
certain point at night like 8:00 p.m.
9:00 p.m. and then it's like I've
watched all the Netflix shows I did
everything that I could do as far as
like work or jobs I worked out
now what I do want to talk tik-tok with
you because I talked to Thomas who is
basically in charge of the hype house
and he said he modeled the hype house
after team ten so I'm just curious what
you make of tick tock and are you at all
worried about the success of hype house
and what's happening there are you
flattered that they modeled what they're
doing off of what you've done
yes no so Thomas was actually a team 10
employee I don't know if he told you
that you might have actually mentioned
that that he yeah yeah no I think it's
great like I want I want everyone to
succeed and I think when there's a new
wave of like content creators coming up
and they're doing well and pushing
creative boundaries I think it's dope as
far as the hype house I just know how
hard it is to keep something like that
work functioning smoothly because
there's so many people and egos and
drama and business and you're living
with your best friends and it's hard to
communicate and at the end of the day
you're in Hollywood which makes
everything 10 times crazier so right I
wish them that I wish them the best of
luck and I think it's cool yes that
people are like modeling you know stuff
off of the things that I've done but I
just it's it's hard it's hard to have a
house like that I know that you and your
brother are at least friendly with Daisy
peach and she left the hype house there
seems to have been some drama that went
on which is wild because when I was
there she was there and everyone seemed
to be getting along
yes yes if you have any sort of like
Intel or advice like oh I don't know I
don't know what happened I would just
tell everyone involved in the situation
there like not go to the internet like
you you'll always regret like going to
the internet and trying to expose people
later yeah there's more Varennes well
for anyone and it's better to just be
the bigger person and keep your head
down and keep doing you
do you have any regrets that you made
via social media in the past I don't
really - have any regrets I have a
tattoo that says no regrets and it's
spelled off no regrets no regrets
so nah I would I would I wouldn't say so
I think everything happens for a reason
and you make mistakes so that you can
grow and learn and and maybe maybe maybe
if I could like that I don't know that's
not on have any regrets how are you
gonna say you just I don't know I'm
gonna say maybe not being related to
Logan Paul I mean honestly that's a good
point she gets in all the controversies
and then people hate me for it and then
the he's the golden child but I'm like
the younger one so they like wanna kick
me down but like it when you think about
it like and we don't have to get into
the details but Logan is always the one
that does worse I've actually talked to
him a little bit about this and just
like him like being involved in like
controversies and stuff and how that's
been for him but I guess I never thought
about how it affected you so it does
affect you like his poor decisions you
feel like affect you in a negative way
yeah honey person yeah i think i think
like i saw someone like comment
something like how did Logan do this but
then Jake still the more hated brother
and I'm ya know that's frustrated yeah
what are you or frustrating what do you
feel like you're hated for the most I'm
like what do you want to say to your
haters I feel like you take a moment to
address I think it's a I think it's a
compilation of a bunch of little things
that like would always like come up like
I think and it started with me jumping
on the news van and then there was just
like one thing that I would be on
training on Twitter for like every three
months like boom this thing boom this
thing boom Cody Koch bullying bloom
anxiety boom fake marriage and then I
think it's all of those like little
things piled up and then the fact that
like I used to just be cringes like if
you watch my
old videos like they're just so cringy
so I think people are like ah screw that
kid you know do you feel like you like
learned a lot about yourself watching
like as you watch your old videos and
like put them together it's kind of like
holding up a mirror to yourself huh ya
know a hundred percent and what's crazy
about it is when I since I was filming
every single day pretty much from the
time I was like 17 or 18 till like 21 I
didn't get to like live a real life like
that's all I would do is like wake up
and film wake up film wake up film and
so when I stopped and put the camera
down like it was like life hit me in the
face and I grew up I matured I figured
out what made me happy I figure out what
I liked I had completely different
friends around me um so yeah it was
definitely like crazy to put the camera
down and now I like I don't like the old
version of myself at all so I think
that's when the haters yeah I get that
but I love that you like hot experience
there had so much self growth I think
that's awesome
people are still so invested in you
because I know you're putting up new
videos every Thursday and they're still
getting millions and millions of views
what do you think it is about your
videos and your life that people are
still so intrigued I I think I think we
just have fun really is what it boils
down to and we're just like we're just a
bunch of kids here in this house that
I'm so lucky to even have and we just
run around and do stupid and film it and
prank each other and we're drinking and
partying and there's hot girls and
there's hot guys and there's dogs and
there's Lambos and like I think they're
just like everything combined and yeah
it's just like being ourselves I guess
yeah do you ever get um tired of all the
party mmm Matt yeah hey I didn't party
in high school and I didn't get to go to
college right so I have to like I'm
going through that like phase as a young
adult now
but I don't think I've gotten tired of
it yeah what does the next I mean once
all of this list like what is the next
chapter it's like for you look like it
has business and work kind of been
affected but it's definitely affected me
a lot
and the fight that I'm gonna do with ksi
is gonna be the focus after this I want
to get that set up for sure because
that's kind of been delayed because of
all of this madness
okay excited to beat your brother right
yeah exactly
Wow and now I'm gonna beat him I'm gonna
knock him out in the first round you
preparing for that right now
not really I mean just working out a
little bit but I don't I don't think I
need to honestly I I it sounds crazy and
like Pete and I said it for my last
fight I just didn't have any credibility
then but now I have credibility because
I said it and it did exactly what
happened and I said I'm gonna knock him
out in the first round and everyone's
like ooh your duty first round he gets
knocked out I'm now I'm saying again and
I have credibility now I I truly believe
that I'm going to not kiss out like
you're gonna do it thank you thank you
you put in the work for the last fight
so I know I know you can do it you
mentioned the the parties and the girls
and the Lambo is but also in your videos
Jake there's like tasers and guns and
like some super scary stuff happening do
you ever worry about what you're putting
out there and do you think there should
be a line ever I think you know I have
as a responsibility to be a role model
and there's definitely stuff we don't
put in the videos so yeah we're stuff
no yeah exactly so there's there's
definitely a line for sure I just think
like and this is what I say like if
people are on the internet they can
access whatever they want right and
they're going to find it eventually but
I do have an influence and a
responsibility so I do draw the line and
it's crazy a night cuz I tweeted the
other day I said don't blame me my
little my person don't blame me
my role model was little Wayne growing
up like I would literally steal my mom's
computer when she wasn't there and like
go online and watch like the little
Wayne documentary and like he was my
favorite what does sort of the next
chapter of the Jake Paul life look like
um working on working on music and
content and just music like you want to
be a singer not a singer just like an
artist in general
musically it naturally like excuse
hip-hop because that's why I could
listen to growing up and it's my
favorite and yeah I have some I have
some songs in the stash I have a song
with an early choppa and we did a music
video too that I've just been waiting to
post it so lots of music this year
knocking out ksi and just new videos
every Thursday do we do we hear you like
rap on this on these tracks yeah yeah
before I let you go can we limps at your
compound will you give us a mini tour
yes okay ready here we go I'm turning
over this one okay okay this way see
your dog is that your dog yes this is
Thor Thor come here say hi
it's Entertainment Tonight Oh cutie
honey oh this is my friend this is the
main entrance area Scott like that's big
hole policy and thinking those are those
stickers on your wall or what is that oh
that's fan art this is the basketball
court area oh my gosh do you think I'll
make a shot yeah let's try it
okay I believe in you yeah
oh I made it what the heck that was
crazy
you practice that no this is the kitchen
awesome
this is the this is a table and this is
the editing room wherever all the
editors edit stuff
how many Pete all their editing stuff
right now hi dad are you guys editing
you better be editing they're gonna get
fired
um what else do we got here all that
that's Jeff Byron hi this is a pantry Oh
someone's showering in there and now
I'll show you the gym your house is
amazing thank you
it's literally like a dream come true
yes the gym oh my god that's so nice in
there it's my favorite part of the whole
house is yeah sure well show you the
backyard okay it's turning into
Entertainment Tonight it cribs yeah this
is art this is our version of cribs like
is the wife I'm still working it stops
but now it's back again hey oh oh
they're having other people in the pool
hmm
I like that you don't even know that
there's people in your own pool
downstairs well thank you so much for
taking the time confer giving us a tour
of your house your house is amazing
thank you so much um you know the et
loves you and we love keeping up with
you so make sure that you keep it posted
on all of your endeavors and on this ksi
bikes I'm really excited about that
I got you I'll keep you up to date with
everything all right thanks Jay thank
you so much bye Katie
[Music]
you